sommes en détresse il faut démonter
c'est quand on a démantelé sangatte
c'était sarkozy sacré calais on a dû
manquer calais maintenant on a le temps
de grande synthe qui tient le lieu du
chaos migratoires des affrontements
entre l'immigrant la vérité il faut être
clair c'est que l'immense majorité de
ces migrants sont des clandestins ils
sont là pour des raisons purement
économiques qui n'ont pas vocation à
rester en france
donc il faut les expulser et s'agissant
les demandeurs d'asile il faut expulser
ceux qui sont déboutés du droit d'asile
et ceux qui demandent l'asile et doivent
le faire depuis les pays puissent depuis
les pays limitrophes balle vers leur
pays d'origine dans l'immense majorité
des cas en irak ou en syrie par les
tanks oui mais vous savez aussi que
l'immense majorité de ces clandestins et
le ministre de l'intérieur l'avait
reconnu à quelques mois il ne veut se
fut absolument pas la guerre ils sont là
d'abord pour des motifs économiques vous
le savez très bien qu'à calais à
grande-synthe
l'immense majorité d'entre eux ce ne
sont ni des syriens ni des irakiens donc
il faut arrêter de dire ça aux français
un peu pour les culpabiliser en dix ans
il fut la guerre et puis je vous dire
pour aller plus loin est ce que le
critère il fait qu'il fut un pays en
guerre c'est un critère suffisant je
crois pas parce qu'il ya 260 millions de
personnes qui habitent dans des pays en
guerre nous aussi on prend ce cri d
allah eh bien on aura une submersion
total on peut pas accueillir des gens
uniquement parce qu'il fut un pays en
guerre vous savez que le droit d'asile
normalement au sens strict c'est ça se
limite aux personnes qui sont persécutés
dans leur pays personnellement à raison
de leurs options philosophiques ou
religieuses bon ou politique donc
l'immense majorité d'entre eux ne se
trouva option pas dans ce cas là je
crois qu'il faut à la galerie filet ils
fuient la misère bien sûr mais on peut
pas les accueillir l'assimilent de
chemin et 9 millions de pauvres on n'a
rien à leur offrir
ya pas d eldorado français il ya salle
de bains y avons été là se sont
installés en france aujourd'hui et des
expériences qui ont été menées qui sont
allés dans nos contrées ça s'est bien
passé au sort des gens sachent et vous
partirez pas pour l'instant à continuer
mais est ce que vous croyez que c'est
juste très franchement d'accueillir des
migrants aux frais du contribuable ce
sont des clandestins on les loge gratuit
c'est la solidarité y compris si c'est
l'annoncé non on n'a pas demandé le
radio en l'occurrence ça a été décidé la
politique de relocalisation a été décidé
par l'union européenne votée par la
droite et par la gauche sans demander
l'avis aux français ensuite les
préfectures un poste de décision dans
les petites communes à qui on demande
pas leur avis qui sont déjà qu'ils
subissent déjà le marasme agricole la
baisse des services publics et qui
subissent maintenant cette immigration
et ça crée une injustice
portable parce que ce qu'on fait pour
des clandestins on les loge on les
nourrit même souvent y compris dans des
centres de vacances spacieux c'est ce
qu'ont fait pas pour des français qui
dorment dans la rue dans la voiture le
monde